digamos que damos clases de estadística
en una universidad hemos aplicado un
examen y queremos conocer la relación
entre la cantidad de tiempo de estudio
de nuestros alumnos y el porcentaje de
respuestas correctas que tuvieron en su
examen y lo que hicimos fue calificar
todos los exámenes establecimos estos
rangos los que estudiaron de 0 a 20
minutos los que estudiaron de 21 a 40
minutos los que estudiaron de 41 a 60
minutos y los que estudiaron más de 60
minutos estos son nuestros rangos de
tiempo de estudio y también creamos
rangos para el porcentaje de respuestas
correctas de 0 a 19 por ciento de
respuestas correctas de 20 a 39 por
ciento de 40 a 59 por ciento de 60 a 79
por ciento y de 80 a 100 por ciento de
respuestas correctas y después vemos qué
porcentaje de nuestra población total
estudiantil cae en cada una de estas
categorías por ejemplo 2 por ciento de
nuestros estudiantes estudiaron de 21 a
40 minutos y obtuvieron entre 80
por ciento de respuestas correctas en el
examen 16% estudio más de una hora más
de 60 minutos y obtuvieron entre 40 y 59
por ciento de respuestas correctas en el
examen así que aquí tenemos una tabla de
dos vías describen una distribución
conjunta entre podemos ver esto como dos
variables el tiempo de estudio y el
porcentaje de respuestas correctas y en
este vídeo vamos a ver dos ideas nuevas
alrededor de esta distribución conjunta
una es la idea de la distribución
marginal distribución marginal y esta es
la idea de que puedo descomponer mi
clase con base en estas dos variables
pero qué tal si me interesa solamente la
distribución de una de las variables por
ejemplo sólo me interesa el porcentaje
de respuestas correctas y no me interesa
el tiempo de estudio sí me interesa
solamente el porcentaje de respuestas
correctas puedo tener aquí el total de
cada uno de estos renglones y terminaré
con esta distribución aquí vemos que el
20% de mí
obtuvieron del 80 al 100 por ciento de
respuestas correctas también veo que el
30 por ciento de mis estudiantes
tuvieron entre 60 y 79 por ciento de
respuestas correctas en el examen veo
que el 35 por ciento de mis estudiantes
tuvieron entre 40 y 59 por ciento de
respuestas correctas el 10 por ciento de
mis estudiantes tuvieron entre 20 y 39
por ciento de respuestas correctas y
finalmente el 5 por ciento de mis
estudiantes tuvieron de 0 a 19 por
ciento de respuestas correctas lo que
hicimos fue calcular el total de cada
uno de estos renglones y verán que todo
esto suma 100% esto describe la
distribución de las calificaciones en mi
clase si alguien solamente nos diera
esta columna
podríamos decir bueno el 20% de mis
estudiantes obtuvo del 80 al 100 por
ciento de respuestas correctas pero no
tendríamos idea de cómo se descompone
esto con respecto al tiempo de estudio
de cada estudiante este tipo de
distribución se le llama distribución
marginal porque podemos ver que está
escrita en el margen de la tabla
pusimos el total de cada renglón y lo
escribimos en el margen y aquí podemos
encontrar otra distribución marginal y
es la distribución de la cantidad del
tiempo que pasan mis estudiantes
estudiando y para esto vamos a calcular
el total de cada una de las columnas y
veremos esto de aquí el 7 por ciento de
mi clase estudio entre 0 y 20 minutos el
15% de mi clase estudio entre 21 y 40
minutos el 43% de mi clase estudio entre
41 minutos y 60 minutos el 35% de mi
clase estudió más de 60 minutos y si
solamente veo esta distribución marginal
de acá la distribución marginal del
tiempo de estudio no voy a poder ver el
detalle de este 35% de los que
estudiaron más de una hora no sabré cómo
fueron sus calificaciones y nuevamente a
esto se le llama distribución marginal
porque está escrito al margen en este
caso el margen inferior de esta tabla si
yo veo esta distribución marginal no voy
a tener idea de
como les fue en el porcentaje de
respuestas correctas de estos
estudiantes ahora hay otro tipo de
distribución aquí que está relacionada a
estas distribuciones conjuntas y se
refiere a la distribución de una
variable dependiendo del rango que nos
interesa de la otra variable si yo
quiero conocer la distribución
de las calificaciones
entre los que estudiaron más
de 60 minutos como obtendré yo esto pues
voy a ver la columna de las personas que
estudiaron más de 60 minutos y aquí
encontraré esta distribución de
calificaciones en este grupo 10% obtuvo
de 80 a 100 por ciento de respuestas
correctas el 5 por ciento obtuvo de 60 a
79 el 16 por ciento obtuvo de 40 a 59
ninguno de ellos
0 por ciento obtuvo de 20 a 39 y el 4
por ciento obtuvo de 0 a 19 por ciento
de respuestas correctas así que esta
distribución de una variable dado cierto
rango de valores de la otra variable a
esto se le llama distribución
condicional porque llegamos a una
distribución que está condicionada por
el valor de otra variable así que esto
de aquí es una distribución condicional
la idea principal aquí es que tenemos
esta tabla con dos variables en donde
tratamos de estudiar cómo se relacionan
estas dos variables si nos interesa la
distribución de una sola de estas
variables por ejemplo el tiempo de
estudio sumamos las columnas aquí
y obtendremos esta distribución marginal
si nos interesa la distribución del
porcentaje de respuestas correctas
obtenemos el total por renglón y
obtendremos esa distribución y si nos
interesará la distribución de una
variable en este caso la distribución de
calificaciones dado o condicionado por
el valor de la otra variable entonces
tendremos una distribución condicional